MARK MIRCHANDANI:
In this episode,
we'll go over the 9th lab
and the baseline data, ML,
and the AI quest on Qwiklabs.
Cloud ML Engine, Qwik Start.
Cloud ML Engine mainly
does two things.
It enables you to train machine
learning models at scale
by running TensorFlow training
applications in the cloud.
And it hosts those trained
models for you in the cloud
so that you can use them to
get predictions about new data.
This lab provides an
introductory walkthrough
of how to train a TensorFlow
model both locally
and on Cloud ML Engine.
Then we'll learn how to deploy
your trained model in the Cloud
ML Engine for serving.
You'll train your model
to predict the income
category of a person using the
United States census income
data set.
A basic familiarity with
Python and Linux commands
will be helpful for
this, but not necessary.
Now, here's the
beauty of Qwiklabs.
You'll get to work directly
with all of the resources
you need to learn these basic
skills in a real environment
without needing
an account on GCP.
If you have an
idea and if you've
wondered if GCP
is right for you,
you can start here with
little to no cost for you.
Completing all the
labs in this quest
earns you this badge to
recognize your new skills.
You can show off your badge
on your resume or social media
channels.
Next on our quest,
Data Studio Qwik Start.